[Music]
let's talk about something everyone
wants to discuss and that's simon
cowell's the x factor
[Laughter]
come on man
next factor premiered last night
you can't what boo
it's not my show
i'm just you can't walk five feet on
earth right you could go to the bottom
of the sea and there's a billboard for
the x factor i know
am i not right these things are
everywhere commercials everything now a
lot of people aren't sure what's the
difference between this new show the x
factor and american idol
all right and there's been some
confusion how are these shows different
so fox is now running these brand new
promos
if you liked american idol then you'll
love the x factor someone said to me how
is it difficult it's totally different
we've got simon and paula yes but we
dropped the dead weight we got rid of
randy and replaced him with this guy he
looks just like randy only he's slightly
thinner and he never says dog that's
right the x factor is dog-free dog free
plus our ryan seacrest is british
auditions are in full swing and we've
got the other soda the x factor it's
american idol but with a totally
different randy otherwise it's totally
the same
[Applause]